Hey guys real quick I just wanted to tell you about our sponsor Threat Locker now wait wait
before you hit the skip forward button let me just say this most of the stuff that holds my attention
nowadays is red team stuff as well but I sat down with the Threat Locker team this past week to do
a demo of their EDR software and it was super technically fascinating how this thing works so
check this out you drop this thing on a system right and for the first week or so it's creating
a policy and a profile for that system it's logging all the executables what child processes are being
spawned the files and their hashes that sort of thing and it's creating this policy okay then after
the learning mode is up we're in secured mode and that policy gets put into place and anything that's
not on that allow list is immediately auto denied that's the zero trust piece right so in addition
to that they've got a bunch of crazy features like ring fencing and dynamic access controls that would
stop a malicious hacker at pretty much every step along the way actually I was watching this demo
and I was kind of freaked out because I have no idea how I would cope with getting dropped into a
Threat Locker system as a red teamer anyway if you want to learn more about this head over to
ThreatLocker.com and request a demo and when you do ask for my boy Andrew his demo was super to the
point and he was able to answer all my technical questions all right cool back to the show yo yo yo
what's going on everybody this is techno geek uh Joel we're doing a solo episode today um so this one is
going to be all focused on part-time bug bounty um you know as Justin is a full-time bug bounty hunter
but I am a part-time bug bounty hunter and uh this was a requested episode from um some of the listeners
um within our discord server so I wanted to take some time to talk about some strategies and some
different aspects of the part-time uh bug bounty hacking life so to speak um I'm a lot more versed on
than I then Justin is I think so I it's definitely a unique perspective and I wanted to just share
some of my thoughts share some of my strategies share some of the tips and tricks and all that sort
of good stuff uh all around that but first I wanted to talk about some news uh so I I know the last few
episodes have been interviews so um I don't know if there's been too much news but there were two main
things that I want to talk about um that had come up in the last couple weeks um the first one was a
really cool post by uh retro reg with a zero uh on zero reg.dev that's that's their blog um patrick peng
um and this blog post was all about an evernote bug that they found that was it started as a font
injection basically javascript injection into pdf.js within the evernote um desktop application
and they were able to escalate that all the way up to remote code execution so it's a really really
awesome blog post um it's very in-depth it talks about sort of the whole strategy the whole mindset
the the whole you know behind the scenes of what went into finding the bug and how they were able
to locate this um basically what they were able to do is they they found that evernote uses pdf.js which
is very large very well-known uh javascript library for um rendering pdfs and within this there's this
font um this font you know construct or whatever I'm not sure what the right word is directive I guess
um and you can create these font objects and the way that it's parsed by pdf.js is faulty and you can
use this to basically sync all the way into a function creation call within the javascript that creates a
new javascript function to get arbitrary javascript execution so from there you have javascript
execution when a pdf gets loaded and rendered by pdf.js within the evernote app but due to the
restrictions that were in place for security purposes you couldn't steal their cookies you
couldn't you know take over the account very easily you couldn't do do much at that point but there is
this inter-process communication um you know functionality that's built into these electron apps
that allows um apps to talk with different parts different other parts of the app um you know
there's like bridges and there's you know sort of sectioned off parts of the application that are
communicated through this ipc process and through this there was a specific ipc handler called like
the broker bridge um where you could do all these different actions and one of those actions ended up
being that you could open file attachments um and so through this very elaborate payload which uh
is if you read through it you're like what the heck is this um but it he he does a great job of sort of
breaking down all the different parts and what each part means and how it works and and so on um and it
basically allows you to put through a file path like calc.exe that will you know fully execute and open
on the uh on the on the victim when the pdf gets rendered and opened by the evernote application so
it's a really really awesome blog post very very cool um great research uh really does a great job of
demonstrating how you can sort of take that to the next level because i think you probably could have
just submitted it as is and said hey you know i have this vulnerability i can execute javascript
within the pdf when it loads done you know maybe it's a medium maybe it's a high or something and
just call it a day but um he really pushed through went the extra mile and found that that impact
there and uh and got it all the way to uh remote code execution code execution file execution not
really sure which which one it would be i guess not really rc but file execution remote file execution rfe
anyways um yeah so very very cool check out that blog post read read through it um
i know a lot of electron apps are out there it's a very interesting attack surface if you ask me
because it's sort of that bridge between um where xss starts to affect client applications there's a ton
of electron apps out there i think a really famous example is um discord uh i don't know if it's still
fully electron but it's javascript based um and you know it basically is has a console and everything so
um yeah there's there's definitely a lot of applications out there that are using javascript
and are using electron and it's probably a probably a ripe attack surface for some vulnerabilities um
cool the next bug blog post i want to talk about was from acid note as always the folks over at acid
note are doing crazy crazy awesome research um and this one was a very elaborate bug chain in service now
um that let them escalate to um being able to access basically all of your service now data
um so it started out that they were they noticed that there was this strange decoding behavior where
uh there's sort of two levels of um protection on this rendering there's there's this template renderer
um and if you can manage to get some tags through this template rendering process then you would have
you know potentially very serious implications uh through full template injection and so they started
looking through the service now application and they found a specific spot where there uh there's no
escaping explicitly being done on user input um and they were able to find a way to get a user
control parameter that just dumps directly into the page and they started fiddling around with it so
um acid note does a really awesome job of sort of walking you through their thought process as well of
you know this is what we tried this didn't work then we looked here oh we noticed this interesting
thing then we tried that that didn't work oh we noticed another thing and so on so it's a very very
good read it's very easy very digestible but it's it's an awesome demonstration of how you can
escalate a bug so they went back and forth basically with the application they noticed okay there's a
sanitizer here oh we can only put certain tags through all right style tag is allowed we use a
style tag to escape the html now we can put arbitrary tags in okay now how do we actually get
this to do what we want we want to use this evaluate tag so that we can actually run our own code
uh in the template execute in the template uh rendering engine right but you can only use these
certain types of tags so they try you know defining their own tag they try changing the namespace there's
a specific check for that they can't define the namespace um then they try overriding the default
namespace uh and then there's another check on that they go and they look how does that check work oh the
check works with a regex is the regex satisfactory no you can bypass it with single quotes instead of
double double quotes and so and so on and so on so it's a really really awesome bug um it's it's super
super cool that shows again sort of this thought process of um you know sort of one step at a time
getting past these security controls testing iterating figuring out how to continue to escalate this
further and further and further until you get to sort of your maximum input impact uh point and um
yeah it's a really really awesome bug um at the end of the day they were able to get you know
arbitrary file read essentially on the server so they could read um you know user uh data they could
read um the config files for the server they could also on a lot of instances i guess there's this
uh cross uh server communication thing so similar kind of like an ipc but it's not inner process it's
it like inner node um and it basically is just rce as a service so you can just run commands you can
run curl and just have it you know run whatever you want um that worked uh evidently it seems so
there was a lot of really interesting stuff that they were able to do um and since they have sort
of this evaluate context where they're within um the template engine they have access to different
classes and and all sorts of very complex sort of attack vectors uh that are that are now available
to them because they're within like sort of java java execution context so it's a very very
interesting blog post definitely go check it out it's on the asset note uh website and yeah um last
thing i'd be nervous if i didn't mention this obviously crowd strike stuff uh i don't really
have much to say about this from a bug bounty perspective uh that it wasn't really bug bounty
related it's just some crazy uh crazy security stuff that came up uh in the last couple weeks
um for those of you who don't know there was a crowd strike um they pushed i guess a bug
or something in one of in the crowd strike agent on windows and it was causing blue screens it
created huge outages all around uh the world all around tons of industries i believe there were
many airlines who were down who were down for like many many days i think delta might still be dealing
with problems um but yeah obviously um just goes to sort of show how stuff can cascade right and
and what the impacts of very small bugs even not necessarily a security bug but just a bug in
general uh can have so just uh just some food for thought hey guys real quick i just wanted to give
a shout to the hacker content team they have been absolutely killing it the past couple months taking
the content from the podcast and condensing it down into consumable social media posts whether it be
shorts or text posts or whatever they've been rocking it so uh i just wanted to give them a shout out
and let you know that they do all sorts of cyber security content as well as social media management
they do technical blogs they do uh comprehensive social media management uh so if your organization
could benefit from any of those types of services make sure you head over to hackercontent.com drop
them a line and mention the podcast when you do to get your first month of cyber security content
marketing services for free all right that's it let's get back to the pod uh all right let's get into
the main content for today which is part-time bug bounty all right so as i mentioned i am a part-time
bug bounty hunter um that is you know my main focus um i uh i work full-time um and i have like a million
other side things that i do all the time including this podcast um and so i think for a lot of people
it can be very daunting to figure out sort of the time management aspects especially and so i just wanted
to cover like sort of a couple different topics around part-time bug bounty and and the first one
is how to balance your time um between like hacking and family and um work and life and not going insane
and all that kind of stuff right so i think the first thing that you really have to do is you have
to choose how serious you want to take this um you know bug bounty can be a very lucrative way to make
a lot of money it can also be just like a very normal side hustle maybe you make you know 100 bucks
a month 500 bucks a month um you know it really it is what you make of it and you can be very successful
or you can take it very casually um i think especially when you're doing it part-time it's
really important to remember you're doing a lot already okay so for whatever your reasons are whether
you're in school whether you're um you're employed full-time whether you have kids whether you're
working two jobs like whatever it is like you've probably already got a lot going on if bug bounty
is something that you're aiming to do part-time um and so it's important to just to recognize that
right um if you're gonna go really hard on this you're gonna go intense you're gonna go all in
then set some strict schedules you know give yourself um you know you say i'm gonna hack two
three hours a day five hours whatever you know from this time to this time and you put that on
your calendar and you block it out and you say sorry i'm busy i i have something going on i have an
appointment you know um you just need to be dedicated and be explicit and be um intentional
about your time when you're if you're gonna be serious about it um along with that like you need
to commit to what your schedule is right so if you're saying that you're gonna work for two hours
a day from you know 7 to 9 p.m then at 7 p.m you drop what you're doing and you go if somebody says hey
can you uh are you free at 7 30 nah sorry i've got something going on right you you have to
commit to that and you need to hold yourself accountable and you need to build accountability
into it right so whether that's tracking your time whether that's having a buddy to hack with
whether that's having someone who you say yeah i hacked today no i didn't hack today um you know
build accountability into your process so that you can hold yourself accountable and you can be honest
with yourself right um if you're gonna track your time there's a couple really easy
ways to do that um you can do it through there's a great application i like called clockify which
basically you can just set projects and it's just a desktop app and you click start stop you say
i'm working on this and it tracks your time um you can view all your stats it syncs online it's free
easy it's great um if you don't want to do that you can just use a timer on your phone um you can
uh track it in a google sheet um i've done that as well actually this year is a new thing for me i've
been tracking all of my time spent hacking i've been tracking how many bugs i submit um bounties
that i earn every single day of the year um just so that you know have those numbers and if you're not
hacking you put a zero in there all right that's how it works that's called being honest you got to be
honest with yourself with yourself if you're going to take this seriously uh which i think you should
um regardless of how intense you take it you need to be honest with yourself how much time are you
actually spending how much time how many bugs are you actually submitting how many bugs are actually
getting paid out and then at the end of the year if you don't like what those numbers look like
then you can try and make some changes and you can say okay i wanted to do this but i but i i didn't
and this is what the actual this is what reality looked like versus what i wanted it to look like
what went wrong did i not take it seriously enough like what what happened there um so you know build
build an accountability track your time track you know your your progress be honest about that tracking
with yourself um if you need to find somebody who you can hack with find someone to collab with we got
a ton of people in our discord ctbb.show discord go find some find find a hacking partner find a
hacking buddy it's split 50 50 and just you know go ham um another strategy that i love um that franz
uses and i also like to use sometimes is like using cliffhangers um or you can use any sort of dopamine
chasing strategy that works for you so whether that's um you know setting setting up you know
something that's really exciting and then stopping hacking right before that so that the next day you're
really excited to come and look at that thing that you were looking at the day before um you can do that
or you know if it's changing targets frequently whatever works for you um that like gives you
that rush use that to your advantage um you have to sort of be your own coach in this scenario where
you need to find the strategies that work for you that allow you to work optimally and capitalize on
those so that you are in the optimal space to hack when you want to hack and when you need to hack okay
next picking programs picking programs is a big topic for part-time hackers um because there's
all sorts of questions around you pick one target you pick a bunch of targets you change target targets
three times a day um do you do you hone in and go ham on a single target like what do you do so um
there's definitely a lot of different ways to do this i don't want to get too much into the weeds on like
you should focus specifically on this one program or not if that's your hacking style that's great um
if i always recommend going deep you know getting very intimate with the application finding all of
the routes all of the ins and outs all the little quirks and nuances and abbreviations and everything
about that program so that you are as knowledgeable as an engineer at that company when you're hacking on
that and that will allow you to make connections and tie things together and use those gadgets very very
effectively if you're that comfortable with the application it's going to be a lot harder to do
that if you're not that that's just that's what i found right um that's not to say that you can't
find bugs without doing that right there's tons of ways to do that and i'll talk a little bit about
that later um but you know that's definitely a a good way to keep yourself um you know focused is to
go deep on an application and and focus only on that one application become an expert there um so
one thing that i like to do when i'm looking for programs is optimize for payouts um and impact um
and so i think those two things go hand in hand if you want the highest payout you want the highest
impact right so there's a script that i wrote um it's going to be released to the critical thinkers
hopefully before this episode if not check the discord but um it uh it will be exclusive to the
critical thinkers and it basically does a bunch of program stats using your hacker one token your cookie
whatever off off cookie to look at all the programs that you're on and we'll look at their bounties and
look at their stats on their bounty tables and it will identify programs that are potentially really
good targets um and the way that it does this is that it looks at some of the payout statistics based
on what is the average bounty based on their bounty table what is the percentage of bounties that are
within high high and crit range how far off from the max high and crit are the average payouts for
highs and crits stuff like that so it's a very very useful tool it definitely identified a couple
different programs that me and justin were both very interested in so uh it works and it's it's a it's
a super useful tool i'm working out some minor quirks with the authentication problems for some
reason it works for me but it doesn't work for other people so um i'm i'm still working out some
of the kinks there but it's a very useful tool um so that'll be available to our critical thinker tier but
um you can do that manually as well so if you want just go to your program dashboard your you know
hacker dashboard or whatever start looking through programs and start looking at their tables and see
what percentage of reports or highs and crits how far are they deviating from their payout table in terms
of bounties how how hard are they adhering to their bounty table and cvss and that's going to tell
you how how easy it's going to be in terms of bounties right when you have a program who really
strongly adheres to cvss and their bounty table where it's a high it gets this much it's a crit it
gets this much um that type of program is as a part-time hunter where you want to be spending your
time because you want to be making the most amount of money without fighting back and forth about the
team you if you find a high you want that back right so um that's definitely something to keep in mind
another thing to keep in mind is from the impact scenario right so put yourself in the shoes of
the security team when you are submitting a bug you want to think about what it would be like to be
sitting at your desk as the security team and a researcher with your username
submit a report and it just came into your inbox number one how does it read right so remember that
you're communicating with a real human um and that some real person is going to be reading that report
so how how are you speaking how are you phrasing things is it easy to understand is it overly
complicated is there unnecessary details that don't need to be in there there's a lot of aspects to
writing a good report um that can be solved by just thinking about how it would be by reading it from
the perspective of the security team the other thing is the impact assessment from the security team so
if you're in the shoes of the security team what is your worst case scenario what uh is it user data
is it rce is it accessing some specific service is it being able to bypass this certain role um what is
you know what is the worst case scenario and what are those more or less impactful things that you can
do on that program um as you know if you're on the security team what would make a bug more impactful
what would make a bug less impactful what things would be mitigating factors that an attacker would
need to get around or find a way to bypass in order to raise the impact on their bug um you know when
time is limited when when it's scarce you have to hyper optimize the things that you're looking for
and you have to angle and orient your reports in a way such that they highlight the highest possible
impact scenario for that program so that you can maximize your severity you can maximize your impact
you can maximize your payout right so on the topic of optimizing and especially keeping your flow
as streamlined as possible let's talk about spending your time efficiently um i've mentioned a couple
times impact versus volume are you going for a lot of reports that may be mediums or are you going for
three crits a month one crit a month what is your goal here right um make sure that you're setting your
goals appropriately and that you're not switching back and forth if you are if you have a target and
you constantly change that target you're never going to be able to make progress towards that target
because the target's always shifting so set a target keep that target and continue to focus towards
it if that target is i want to find a crit go until you find a crit don't go for three hours and then
say okay never mind that's actually too hard i want to find a medium now like that's fine but you should
set goals and you should work towards those goals until you achieve it not just constantly shift it
because you're going to feel like you're constantly stalling and it's going to put you in a negative headspace
um another great strategy is to follow douglas day's uh nose talk about looking for the nose in an
application uh douglas day aka archangel a friend of the show friend of the he's been on the pod a couple
times uh he has a great talk about looking for nose in an application which are basically things that are
explicitly called out as you shouldn't be able to do this uh it shouldn't be possible to do this thing
um you know they're it users should only be able to do x y and z right look look at the documentation
read through um what the application says about itself look for permissions look for role-based
access controls um these are the types of things that you want to try and get around those can be
really easy wins and those can also have very strong impact scenarios where you can say here's your
documentation that says you shouldn't be able to do this here's me doing it very very straightforward
cut and dry usually works very very well um another thing for spending your time efficiently is to map
the product and identify your whole attack surface so the first thing that i always try and do when i'm
looking at an application is figure out what am i dealing with what stuff is available to me what looks
interesting where are my possible attack scenarios what possible routes and gadgets do i have available
what endpoint is returning what to me where do i have user info where do i have permissions where do i
have access control checks all sorts of things make these notes take notes write them down right um
super super important that you figure out just the fundamentals of the application that you explore
and you you get hands on time with the application if you're trying to hack it efficiently and you're
trying to be able to make those connections in your brain when you see something funny all right um
for the impact side when when i talked about volume versus impact if you're going to be going after impact
focus on high impact bugs okay you have to set those targets appropriately don't be like oh maybe i'll
find an idor that leaks user info maybe you will and that could be a very severe bug but that's going
to depend on the program and that's going to depend on their impact scenario that's going to depend on
their risk model right so again when you're putting yourself in the shoes of that security team think about
what their risk model looks like what is their threat and impact model is it leaking user data or is it
account takeover is it access to internal applications is there a walled garden going on right so
look for account takeovers look for ssrfs look for ways to bypass parsers pdf exports file exports template
injection rce right there's a lot of really juicy scenarios nowadays that aren't just all in the browser that are really high impact
um that are really high impact and if you focus just on those you're definitely going to find
at least a few of them um and as i mentioned going going deep um becoming super intimate with the
application again like the those couple of hours that you spend every single day over one week two weeks
a month that will add up to a lot of time and you will become very very well versed with that application
and as soon as you see a bug you're going to be able to connect the dots in your head and you're going
to be able to to write up a bug immediately you're going to you're going to know exactly what to do
you're going to see it you're going to go oh i have a thing for this yeah so last thing i wanted to talk
about streamlining streamlining your process make it efficient um how do how do we how do we add some
grease into the system how do we you know slow as smooth smooth smooth as fast whatever how do we make
this better how do we streamline our process okay step one just like grease reduce friction okay this is
going to depend person by person you need to find where the highest friction areas are in your process
so when you're hacking there's going to be things where you're going to be like this is so annoying
i hate this part uh this is always so annoying for me it's so frustrating that i have to do xyz
and i'm not going to start hacking because i have to do that or it off you know it's off putting right
whatever those friction points are whatever those those negative annoyances are you need to fix those
things okay so whether that's creating report templates because writing reports sucks whether
that's using bash aliases and creating shell scripts for yourself that you can execute to do a bunch of
different commands at the same time because remembering all that stuff is annoying whether that's creating
custom automations and tools and scanning suites find your own blockers and solve your own blockers
right this is a really important part of your process that you can't just let these problems
live and say well i have a limited amount of time so uh i i just need to hack i can't go and fix this
problem no spending time fixing a problem is not a waste of time okay when you have a problem you
spending time fixing that is really really important it's very important to actually spend time
fixing that problem that is part of optimizing and part of fixing that for every single time that you
hack after that if you have a problem you fix it once never again it's very you know so make sure to
spend the time to fix those things on on the other hand don't overdo it okay it's so easy to just
say oh i could optimize this oh let me automate that keep it simple right keep it simple but if it's
clunky if it's if it's a blocker if it's creating more problems than it's solving optimize it okay
don't over complicate it but but don't let it you know be a blocker right so find your own problems fix
fix those problems optimize your process next take notes i said this at least twice during this episode
take notes take notes take notes take notes and and the most important part of taking notes is
reviewing your notes my goodness i cannot tell you how many times i've taken notes and i i just don't
even i don't even look at them i just i'm just writing stuff down not even looking at what i'm
writing not weeks go by i'm like wow i've taken a lot of notes don't even read them read your notes you
took the notes for a reason okay in your notes you should have a lot of very useful tips for yourself
otherwise you're taking inefficient notes so your notes should be things that you in the future
want to look back at so look back at it okay it's very important that's a very important part of
taking notes is reading the notes okay record videos record audio for yourself doesn't have to be
video you don't you go oh my face is ugly i can't don't i don't want to be on video great record a
voice memo for yourself about what you were doing at the end of your hacking session brain dump into
either a video or an audio you can do this for gadgets you can do it for your whole hacking session
you can do it however you want loom is a great way to do this because it records your face and your
screen you can use obs if you don't want to use some other software you can use freaking
quick time on mac um you know there's tons of ways to record your screen um and your audio record
to yourself you're just talking to yourself and brain dump because the next time that you go to hack
you can open that video you got you know a three to five minute video that you could just listen get
right back into that headspace that you're at at the end of your last hacking session you can jump
right back into it without having to try and figure stuff out again um otherwise taking notes
notion i use notion for my notes it's great it's like kind of markdown niche on steroids it's really
really nice um it has a lot of awesome features like you know collapsible sections and tables and
whatever there there's a lot of stuff you can do with notion i think there's another tool called obsidian
i want to say and that's like more open source brain mapping type note taking stuff there's a ton of
options out there you can use evernote if you want uh as we talked about earlier i don't know that's
i'll leave that up to the bill lister um uh you can also use a whiteboard i just bought a whiteboard you
can't see it it's off screen right now but i bought a massive whiteboard for my wall um so you can just
you know write down some notes dump stuff on there you know map stuff out on there um sticky notes i love
sticky notes i have a pad of sticky notes right here i keep them on my desk i have pencil on my desk
and if uh sometimes even in the middle of the podcast justin will say something and i don't want
to never interrupt him or i have a thought uh that i want to you know make a note of or an idea that i
don't want to leak on the podcast and uh i'll take a sticky note and i'll write it down and i'll just put
it on my desk or i'll put it on my monitor take notes very good sticky notes notion notes
video notes whiteboard notes notes very good okay that is pretty much all i've got um
there's obviously a lot more that you can do but i think sort of the best advice that i have is iterate
take notes and identify the blockers in your process right streamline what you do when again when
time is limited you have to optimize okay if you want to be the most efficient hacker that you can in the
amount of time that you have as a part-time hacker you have to find the ways to make your process the
best as possible you need to figure out the way that you want to hack whether that's high impact
whether that's high volume whether that's focusing on one program whether that's changing all the time
and you need to find the ways that work for you that are successful and figure out the goals and the
things that you want to get out of this if you want to get a certain amount of money set that money as
a goal track it in a spreadsheet track it in clockify track it on your phone track it in a notes app track
it however you want to track it and hold yourself accountable right be honest with yourself and it's
okay to take breaks to fix problems to let yourself recharge and to recognize that you are doing a lot
and it's just a part-time thing so you you know you get out what you put in so you got this good luck
part-time hackers i believe in you i'm with there i'm with you on there you got this good luck see you
on the leaderboards peace and that's a wrap on this episode of critical thinking thanks so much for
listening and if you want more critical thinking content head over to ctvb.show discord join the
discord there's lots of great conversations and chats going on over there and if you want to support
the show there's the discord subscriber tiers which give you access to master classes amas hack alongs
exclusive scripts and an exclusive chat channel with us we'll see you there